&gt;&gt; This one was c. If you got it right, excellent work. Just like in the first
practice problem, we want to get the boundary line, so let's solve this
inequality for y. First we subtract 3x from both sides, then we divide both
sides of the inequality by negative 5. Remember, both these terms need to be
divided by negative 5. And here we need to be very careful. We divided by a
negative so we need to reverse the inequality sign. Now we're ready to graph.
The y intercept is negative 3, which is here. 3 units down from the origin. Our
slope is positive 3 5ths, so we rise 3 units up and run 5 units to the right.
Now, I have two points and I can draw my boundary line. I have a less than
symbol so I need to draw a dash line, because I can't include points on the
line. And finally, we use a test point to determine which region should be
shaded, the top region or the lower region. If I plug in 0 for x and 0 for y I
get 0 is less than negative 3. I know this statement isn't true, so I don't want
points in this region. I want this region. This should be my solution region and
I can test another point in this region to be sure I'm going to use the point
zero negative four and remember you could choose any point in this region. It
wouldn't matter. If I plug in 0 for x and negative 4 for y, I get negative 4 is
less than negative 3. This is a true statement, so yeah, I did this problem
correctly.